[Music]
hi everyone my name is Devin and today
we're playing what's in the box the
horror edition with the cast of The
Turning so if you've ever wondered what
it's like to be a nanny working in a
haunted house you should check out the
turn bad dreams
the turning was so scary make sure that
you empty your bladder before you see
this bad boy I play flora there's a lot
of mystery terror what happened to your
last nanny like I'd tell
I laid my eyes she's kind of a dick
I know what you're afraid of because it
just constantly has a wrestling match
going on in his head shouldn't be in
here yeah I play cage this is my first
live in chop and I come into the house
of these kids live in hello you're
looking at I'm gonna sneak in your boots
this is our mystery box and you're gonna
slide your hand right in all the way in
there and whoever can guess what's in
the box and what they're feeling wins
I like teeth chattering nervous but so
this is our first time right yeah Ben do
you want to try it straight up a bug
let's reveal what's in the box
[Music]
do you know this is active baby it's a
baby
all right let's turn around and see
what's in this box I feel like this is
such a after what you just what did you
do oh I'm so sorry angel rattled by the
Concord thing alright guys
oh my god let's see what's in this box
he wants to put their hand in first you
do it baby
then do it what's in it but it was very
cold
yeah describe the audience was it like
chicken or something chicken breast
follow a question do you think you put
this in your mouth don't
it's probably nothing she have to suffer
so thank you guys so much for playing
what's in the mystery box you want you
for celebrate then you are the winner so
you can tell everyone you know make sure
you go see the terrine in theaters
January 24th yes sorry if I scared you
[Music]